New York Fashion Week is underway and a
nine-year-old with dreams of becoming a
supermodel is already making historic
strides this is Daisy Mae Demetri
strutting her stuff yesterday she is the
first child double amputee to walk in a
show at New York Fashion Week our
national correspondent Jericka Duncan
spoke with her Jericka Daisy Mays story
is really inspiring yes she's very
inspiring very beautiful girl both
inside and out and in many ways she's
just like any other fifth grader she's
in school she says she prefers English
over math she loves gymnastics and doing
cartwheels
but it's her moves on the runway that
exude the most competence you were
awesome going down that runway how does
it feel
Daisy made Dimitri was a natural at New
York Fashion Week Dimitri was born in
Birmingham England with a rare condition
that required both of her legs to be
amputated but that hasn't stopped her
here she is strutting her stuff earlier
this year at London kids Fashion Week
where she even broke out a cartwheel
Ozzy's a special unique child and doing
stuff all the doctors told me who would
never really be possible Daisy Mays
father Alex says his daughter's
blossoming modeling career came
seemingly by chance he just so happened
on TV pops up disabled modeling agency
so I put the idea to her so you say to
her do you want to be a supermodel and
you say yeah we had an instant
connection designer any kupenga dish
boots on took notice Daisy Mae is now a
brand ambassador for her Lulu Gigi
clothing line I want people to see that
beauty is not one one-sided is a
multi-faceted thing what advice do you
have to children like yourself
just never get off and just stay away
him day Daisy Mae will represent Lulu as
Gigi again later this month this time at
Paris Fashion Week will she will model
at the top of the Eiffel Tower and I'll
get you a nice little girl and the
confidence that she has at such an early
age and I prefer English over math like
she does yeah I do too my kind of girl
Thank You jury go inside a now tree